I'm so happy to see you both.
Hi. Hi you guys.
Hey, I'm so happy to see you both as well. Hi.
I'm so excited to be celebrating
and talking about this show.
I can't stop watching it.
Jessica Biel, you've been nominated
for an Emmy before for "The Sinner."
(audience applauds)
I believe With all of my heart
that this will be your next Emmy nomination.
Oh my goodness. Geez. (laughs)
I really do.
You're so incredible in this show.
And Melanie, I also believe you will be nominated
for an Emmy for this show.
(audience applauds)
No. I-
And then I also just had the esteemed pleasure
as we all did, watching you win your award
at the Critics Choice, and then you get up there
and you kind of do this thing that goes viral
and wild afterwards, because you thanked your nanny.
Yeah, I mean, I was kind of surprised
that it became like a thing afterwards,
because when I think about the people
who are the biggest part of my life,
who make it possible for me to work,
it's my husband and my nanny.
She's just the coolest person in the world.
And she works so hard.
And how lucky am I that I have a person like that
taking care of my child so I can really go to work
and concentrate and not be worried.
I mean, what a fortunate thing.
Melanie, I really think you might have opened a new door
for all of us women to acknowledge people
in our inner circle in a different way.
And I thank you for that.
It's big deal.
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much for saying that. Thanks.
I fully agree.
I think what a beautiful thing to do
and there's no way my life, either,
would exist without the two wonderful nannies
that care of my beautiful kids.
So thank you, Melanie.
And thank you to everyone out there
who's making everyone else's life
possible outside of the house.
We could not do it without the support teams
that we have, impossible.
And we shouldn't be ashamed
to tell the truth about that, I don't think.
Well, it's funny,
we do live in a different, more modern society.
And the show that you're doing,
is a bit aesthetically of a period piece.
It's a true story.
You guys, this is one of the most eerie, suspenseful,
it gives my flesh tingles
and makes it crawl in all the right ways.
It's so good!
(Jessica laughs)
How could you make a show this good?
It's intimate, but it just, ah! Ah!
What was your approach to this show, Jessica?
There was a real sense of importance in creating
the mundanity of a suburban life,
especially back in 1980 in a place like Wylie, Texas.
And to sit in those very normal, somewhat eerie,
strange, isolating experiences and to really see,
specifically these two women
in their separate, but similar,
their mindsets which are very different,
but also I really believe going through very similar issues,
with feeling alone and feeling maybe a lot of regret
and a lot of resentment about how their life has turned out.
And I think so many of us,
we can really empathize and understand that feeling.
And there are choices made,
like Melanie, when you're sitting in your house,
you're alone and the baby keeps crying,
and it's like, there's no trickery.
It's the onset of a baby crying repeatedly
throughout the day and the night in different intervals.
And I'm like, this has so many layers to it.
How did you do it?
Well, I mean, I felt her very deeply in my soul.
She was somebody who was a complicated person,
not the easiest person,
and a few people that I talked to, believed
that she had kind of undiagnosed postpartum depression
because it wasn't really discussed in 1980
and she was really struggling.
It just moved me so much that she had no one to turn to.
And it's part of the heartbreak of the story
is 'cause she felt at a certain point
like she could turn to Candy as a friend.
Like she had one friend finally
and then-
Oh yeah, yeah, she could.
(upbeat music)